San Francisco room to some of the
world's most creative young companies
it's even outpacing job growth in nearby
Silicon Valley it has the place to be a
startups from all over the world so why
did these guys head in the other
direction the city is beautiful all the
buildings here are older than our own
country so it's really breathtaking to
just take a walk down the street and
soak in all the history the culture
Sherman Lee and Carl goes na are
preparing for a big funding pitch in a
pub on a Tuesday afternoon that's just
one of the perks of living in London as
they see it the people are supportive to
London inherently has a really strong
startup community and that's proven to
be true anyone that we've met here have
been extremely helpful the childhood
friends are born and bred San
Franciscans their company good audience
help small businesses find the right
followers on social media and engage
with them we essentially help solo music
artists and bands and even music
agencies help them grow their social
media following or the individual
artists to give them the specific
actions that will drive followers the
pair worked at Google and Yahoo before
setting out on their own they were in
talks with US investors who tried hard
to keep them in America but Sherman and
Carl saw the potential of London one of
our mentors is Julia Hawkins who is run
for digital media
at Universal Music and she's been
extremely helpful in making the right
introductions giving us the right advice
she is specifically in London and not in
San Francisco so I don't think those
types of key opportunities so six weeks
in and it's all going well but what
about the future well Sherman and Carl's
summer fling turn into something more
lasting we don't think that far ahead no
I think we'll stay in London for a while
there's not a specific need to move back
unless there are key investors there are
key clients there where we'll just open
an office